you didn't have to follow the news to
know something wasn't right in New York
it's very unexpected like it really
happened out of the blue I said to my
children I'm like is it me or is it
really foggy out here because it was
that bad that I felt my eyesight was
something wrong with my eyes they're
like no it's foggy out air quality is so
bad you could see it and smell it when I
opened my apartment door the hallway
smelled like smoke which was something
that I have never you know experienced
before New York may have had it the
worst but it wasn't alone 12 States
issued air quality advisories all as a
result of wildfires north of the Border
in Canada you know the levels that
people if they were to be outside
especially if they're exercising
breathing faster they're going to be
inhaling particulates at concentrations
at normal smokers would inhale State
officials are advising people to stay
indoors as much as possible The View
here in New York has ranged from hazy to
barely recognized visible and to be
clear there are no clouds in the sky
this is all particulate matter from
Canada a thousand kilometers away and
yet it is blocking our view of the
skyline of Manhattan just over the river
barely a kilometer away from
Philadelphia to Washington DC as far
south as North Carolina schools canceled
outdoor activities when I got back from
school my head was hurting I don't know
I was having really bad headaches and
then my nose started bleeding the very
old and the very young as well as those
with heart or respiratory conditions are
being advised to wear masks Outdoors
scientists blame unusually dry and hot
conditions in Canada for fueling more
than 400 active fires there and their
warning this could be the country's
worst Wildfire season on record people
across the country are being affected
we're seeing vulnerable people at risk
outdoor events canceled kids having to
be kept inside at recess
in New York the air quality alert has
already been EXT
end the Wildfire season typically lasts
until September
Kristen salumi Al Jazeera New York